wir sind hier vom marken jack csu gegen
fdp müssen hier wissenschaftliche
untersuchungen vornehmen da wie kurze
haare proben entnehmen
doch nicht weh
[Musik]
csu gegen fdp marken jack wir wollen
wissen wo wird der gemeinde bierzelt
bayer besser bedient du weißt ja schön
dass sie bei der fdp präsidium haben
die sind ganz lieb im marken jack
volksnähe zum parteivorsitzenden ja der
größte vorsitzende bernd lucke hält
einzug bernd lucke das sind 45 kilogramm
die altere populistische power herr
seehofer zehn extra punkte wenn sie
stehenbleiben seehofer nur bernd lucke
geht auf tuchfühlung mit dem volk 30
punkte für die afd
im marken jack drogenmissbrauch wir sind
vom marken jack csu gegen fdp müssen
hier wissenschaftliche untersuchung
vornehmen da wie kurzer moment nehmen
nur noch nicht wie nahe wien
wissenschaftlich versteht ist ja ja ja
ja ich glaube ich schaue aber er könnte
und nicht könnte sein der vor 45 jahren
neue haschisch geraucht haben
hallo ich bräuchte gerade mal eine
dna-probe plädieren abgehoben sind ein
wissenschaftliches magazin also jetzt zb
ein haar von ihrem bad könnten sie uns
das gibt dann nehmen sie das doch
[Musik]
ehrlich das tut nicht weh ich noch einen
abstrich heimat
alles klar vielen dank bitteschön
die csu ist drogenfrei zehn punkte im
marken jack angst vor dem moslem firma
xy aus xy gibt muss die meisten
verbrechen verübt werden hauptsächlich
und auch die hemmschwelle hinaus sie
heute frau zwecks punkt zu bringen
diese analysen und den ausländern her
also bestimmte jeden fall höher als in
deutschland
bayer macht es nicht er bringt eben
keine ältere frau gegen geld um genau
zum beispiel möchte ich sie bitten sätze
zu vervollständigen wie diesen hier der
islam der islam gehört zur
internationalen welt aber nicht
es ist zwar ein teil von deutschland
auch es müssten nicht unbedingt noch
mehr zuwanderung von muslimischen
ländern gefördert werden
folgende situation stellen sie sich vor
ihr sohn hat sich verlobt wir haben
jetzt drei partner zur auswahl eine
verschleierte muslima b eine schwarze
juden oder c ein anderer mann passt es
ganz schön eine bescheide das ist ja
schon am schlimmsten oder
alles vor dem moslem bei beiden parteien
jeweils zehn punkte im marken jack
respekt vor den staatsmedien wer war das
wird mir das gerade auf dem grund weil
ich nicht das kann ich garantieren
wer war das feuer das ich werde
niemanden verpflichten
wir waren nicht und deutschland darf
niemals rot rot grün regieren das ist
mir das mal eine mehrheit
zusammenbringen wenn die fdp näher kommt
die sind lauter als der redner vorne
das muss dann ist ja ok aber nicht
übertreiben
warum darf ich sie fragen warum warum
sie da so kritisch eingestellt sind
momente die ein geschäft bin das was wir
glauben sie dass sie mit bezwecken wenn
sie hier blödsinn betreiben
sie machen eine aufnahme die ist für die
öffentlichkeit ja das ist das ist
normales kann sich das ist normales
fernsehgeschäft ja ungehalten zu
verbreiten lügen zu verbreiten in
warnungen zu verbreiten der stadt
wahrheiten ist dass ihr geschäft
was sagen sie ja
doch eine demokratie wo jeder das sagen
kann was er möchte sagen sie erhält dann
sagen sie was sie möchten nein sie ist
hat respekt zehn punkte und damit steht
der sieger fest
fazit es gibt einen eindeutigen
populismus sieger und franz josef strauß
kann richtig stolz sein
die fdp schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal